so biden
allowed 5 million barrels from national
reserve to go abroad this is a daily
mail story
uh he shipped 5 million barrels from the
united states to strategic orders abroad
after claiming that releasing them would
help ease americans pain
at the pumps the president faces
accusations of a sneaky slight of hand
as it was revealed that between a fifth
and a sixth of the reserve oil he
bragged about releasing to boost supply
made its way offshore to europe and asia
in june biden authorized the release of
a million barrels a day from april
onwards but his action has done little
to combat soaring gas prices with the
national average sitting at 474 as of
tuesday still far above the 228 a gallon
average
uh from just before he took office from
220 to 474.
five million barrels abroad to europe
and asia and then and that and then one
like how explain to me
we we're mess we're f'ed up with gas
we're in a shortage explain to me how
you think sending all that
overseas is going to help us
what the what does that even mean
like we're sending we don't have it you
guys are paying for it we're sending it
how is that going to make the price go
down like it's like it would seem what
it would seem to me that every decision
that has been made by the biden
administration associated with this
ukraine invasion as we describe it has
been nothing short of disastrous for the
american people while it has been good
for raytheon to a certain extent
obviously because they want more weapons
and the democrats could not push for
more wars and more weapons because they
take money from the raytheons and the
lockheed martins of the world and i can
share with you the numbers and they're
kind of disgusting how much the profits
have gone up since the ukrainian
situation started but also from an
energy standpoint the american people
are getting hosed because of biden's
policies having to do with ukraine and
everything and that and by the way
that's not to say that i'm agreeing with
freaking putin and what he's done in
ukraine obviously but the way we've
handled it those who are being hurt by
it are the american people and certainly
not uh you know some some of guidance
donors for example so the whole thing
just really smells the whole thing
stinks to high heaven so uh i don't
think we can get away from that and i
think it's going to be somebody's going
to be dealing with for quite some time
his foreign policy by the way sucks so
so here's a question for you adam here's
a question for
any one of you guys here but
specifically adam curious here's what
you have to say
how many of the people that voted for
trump and were true believers of trump
flipped on him what percentage
since the january 6th hearings during
his first three years minus kovit
what percentage of the people that voted
for trump flipped on him in the first
three are saying this is a terrible vote
i should have never voted oh very few
okay so how many people who voted for
obama three months three years later
said
you know what a terrible vote i should
never voted for obama very few i agree
of course how many people flipped on
bush three years later saying horrible
what i should have never voted for uh
bush uh a lot because of the iraq war
okay fair how many people said that with
uh clinton three years later
uh not a lot pre-monika none
pre-monarchy again everything i'm saying
primarily
right
how many people within the first three
years who voted for biden are saying
what the hell did i just do a very good
question what do you think that
percentage is because it's not like it's
republicans are being so alive stop
throwing the gun under the bus give the
guy a second chance no no his own people
who voted for him are throwing him under
the bus at this point
and that percentage is a big percentage
of people who voted for this guy i think
i think they they're realizing now it
was like you know when you when you buy
something just you just like you just
want to purchase it
but it was an impulse vote because you
know kovit and the media and with that
that that whirlwind was it was trump and
trump oh he said they came from china
racist all that that whirlwind they were
like all right listen anything will do
they could have literally had a weakened
at bernie's dead body which biden kind
of is they would have voted for anybody
and now now that they're seeing it now
that their wallets are hurting they're
like oh [ __ ] we were i mean
kind of got duped into it you're stuck
with it well though vince to a certain
extent presidencies are circumstantial
you are a uh byproduct of the
circumstances that you inherit to be
fair with trump or to be fair with obama
or to be fair with anybody even this
does that mr mr sleepy yeah um
there are some things you could cogently
say that he has had laid upon him which
were very difficult to manage that said
that's your [ __ ] job i agree okay fdr
didn't say all these freaking nazis this
is not fair no nazis are there you gotta
take them on yeah you know uh when obama
had to deal with the meltdown you know
give him credit he dealt with it i don't
necessarily like the way he dealt with
it but he dealt with it and he helped so
you got to deal with what you're dealt
man those are the cards here you got you
got an h no you got no aces oh sorry and
uh you know people will say that it's a
circumstantial situation for biden but
on top of the fact that he's had tough
circumstances i will give him that this
inflation situation was not made by him
um he's not dealing with it properly nor
is he capable of dealing with it
properly because he's not a strong
leader that's my point
great i i think
i think it's going to be very
interesting how much worse it can get
under him like he's not even wanted to
come out like this one lady democratic
strategist just said to follow i just
want to read this one quote and go to
the last story which is the highland
park it's infuriating said one top
democratic strategist venting
frustrations about biden and his team
our house is on fire and it seems like
they're doing nothing to put out the
fire they're just watching it with the
rest of us so
meaning here's the policies you said you
were gonna go through you have the house
you have every it's all you and you
can't get [ __ ] done we thought you're
gonna get everything done now what do we
do it's catastrophic midterms i just
can't wait for midterms to see what
happens there so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]